If androgen and testosterone are mixed then which one should be
chosen son? Testosterone because
testosterone is also your male androgen.
No, it will never give you such a thing together
which is human sperm here and there,
what four parts do you get
which -  Which four parts are your first
part? Second part is your head part.
If you talk about that is the neck part, what will be the third part?
What will be your middle piece and fourth part will be your
tail part. Let's talk about the right head part.
In the head part.  Firstly, the nucleus will be present
inside which you will get the genetic material.
Apart from this, here you will
get the acrosome, which is your that is the cap like
structure in which
we all know what you get, in which you
get hydrolytic enzymes, right.
Which is your acrosome part, in this you will
find hydrolytic enzymes which will
help in penetrating your egg membrane.